bonjour bonjour
des températures glaciales dans les
roses ce matin le gel c'est invité sur
les voitures et le thermomètre affiché
jusqu'à moins 4 degrés une fraîcheur
rare à Montpellier alors ce matin les
habitants sont sortis bien en miouflés
là j'ai sous les Guignes les mon
pantalon un t-shirt de ski et mon pull
on découvre que il peut faire froid en
hiver c'est quand même assez savoureux
et on a l'impression à chaque fois que
tout le monde panique à tout dire
attendez il va neiger la semaine
prochaine waouh quelle surprise nous
sommes en hiver et toutes les chaînes
info sont en boucle mais ce qu'on en
fait par un peu trop aussi autour de ça
quoi et puis j'ai même un scoop pour
vous c'est que cette année Noël va
tomber le 25 décembre
préparez-vous ça va être dur à vivre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais Michel là le vin blanc tu l'as
mis dans la maison
avec le froid ressurgissent sur le Web
les astuces pour dégivrer le pare-brise
de sa voiture il y a les valeurs sûres
comme le bon vieux grattoir un spray
dégivrants peut aussi faire la faire
d'autres poussent le chauffage à fond en
attendant que font de la glace et puis
il y a les méthodes à éviter comme le
sac rempli d'eau chaude qui peut
endommager une vitre en cas de
microfissure et enfin la technique a
totalement proscrire l'eau bouillante
ça me fait mourir de rire parce que
c'est pas drôle
même faire les courses je sais pas
pourquoi on clique
allez c'est bon on y va c'est parti le
problème c'est qu'en fait on est 10 on
se déplace toujours à deux véhicules on
a un véhicule de 8 places et un de
quatre places ça fait 11 une température
intérieure de 9 degrés dans un gymnase
délabré voici les conditions de travail
au lycée voit l'homme d'Aulnay-sous-Bois
alors que le thermomètre peine à passer
les 0 degré en journée élève et
professeur souffrent et pas seulement en
cours de sport les toilettes ne sont pas
fonctionnelles aussi au-delà du
chauffage parce qu'on parle du chauffage
mais il y a beaucoup d'autres problèmes
[Rires]
obligé de suivre leur cours à la lumière
de leur téléphone dans le froid pour les
enseignants et les élèves de ce lycée
ces images résument la vétusté de leur
établissement que les températures
glaciales rendent insupportables Anne
d'électricité fenêtre mal isolée
et troubé en dans le plafond je vous
jure c'est une anecdote vous raconter
souvent des anecdotes mon grand mon fils
il avait besoin de faire la grosse
commission j'habite à 15 minutes à pied
mais 5 minutes en voiture il m'a appelé
viens me chercher je suis venu le
chercher il a fait sa commission à la
maison et je le redéposé à l'école
c'est incroyable on en rigole je vous
jure c'est pas normal contactez la
région Île-de-France assure avoir engagé
45 millions d'euros de travaux pour
rénover trois bâtiments des travaux qui
seront achevés au printemps prochain les
premiers bâtiments concernés ont été les
BC et D qui le nécessitaient davantage
que le a les coupures d'électricité sont
liées au chantier la région
Île-de-France est totalement mobilisée
sur la situation de ce lycée les travaux
sur le bâtiment à font l'objet d'un
autre projet ils doivent être réalisés
d'ici 2028 qu'est-ce que vous auriez à
dire ce soir à Geoffrey carvalino
conseiller régional du 93 mobilisé pour
les lycées il travaille avec Valérie
Pécresse il est c'est lui qui s'occupe
du projet alors qu'est-ce que vous lui
diriez chers amis Valérie Pécresse vous
allez vous êtes là pour nous contrer
non moi je suis là pour discuter pour
vous expliquer et surtout vous dire ce
qui est en cours mais nous on a la
marque des difficultés
mais est-ce que tu as déjà enfoncé une
vis de ce genre dans un trou non
deuxième première fois tiens ah ben il y
en a des petites et des grandes du coup
et des grandes c'est comme ça c'est mais
les deux fonctionnent pareil d'accord
les deux servent à la même chose c'est
une phrase petite vis c'est une phrase
[Applaudissements]
pierre est-ce qu'on remet la cabane au
milieu du village
quand vous voulez chers amis
la cabane au fond du jardin de pierre
des milliers de commentaires voilà ce
que reçoit Ken kojandi depuis qu'il
s'est montré avec des cheveux sur des
plateaux télé et sur Instagram comme si
de rien n'était pas
des cheveux qui l'a perdu jeûne comme il
l'explique aujourd'hui j'ai perdu mes
cheveux quand j'avais 20 ans ça a été
très dur pour moi très très dur pendant
4 ans j'ai été assez déprimé et ensuite
on va prendre le citron vert et on va
36 Francis vaut caraméliser les
Saint-Jacques
[Musique]
ils sont complètement fous le M gênant
comme une mauvaise blague qui dérape oui
et puis ce fut le temps de l'acceptation
mais ça calvitie est resté un sujet de
conversation et de blague d'où l'idée de
se faire poser une prothèse capillaire
et de ne rien dire une sorte
d'expérience sociale et un coup de comme
réussite pour l'humoriste et si vous
posez la question de savoir si je l'ai
gardé et ben la réponse c'est venez me
voir en spectacle et vous verrez si je
les ai regardés merci beaucoup Pio merci
Mélanie on se quitte sur du Vivaldi sur
la bonne musique ce qui n'est pas tous
les soirs